ils étaient nombreux à ne pas pouvoir
retenir leurs larmes
monfils l'a déjà chroniqueront il est
petit passé le fils du cros les gourmets
des proches de l'adolescent de 16 ans
des amis enseignants aussi se sont
rassemblés en sa mémoire dans ce parc du
quartier saint michel à montréal
je pensais à tout pour lui qui et
comment ils s'y habituer bon c'est
injuste y'a pas de mots assez forts ya
pas avant le début de la marche des élus
ont pris la parole comme le ministre du
patrimoine pablo rodriguez
qui a été la cible de critiques de
citoyens qui réclament de meilleures
interventions du gouvernement fédéral
concernant l'accès aux armes à feu le
gouvernement fédéral cache son inaction
derrière une oeuvre la passion diarrhée
verbale qu'est ce qu'il faut faire la
surface il faut que le gouvernement
fédéral prenne pas le dis dans ce
dossier comment expliquer la mort
violente de trois adolescents dans les
derniers mois montréal cette
intervenante et mais plusieurs
hypothèses
on alla covit qui a pas aidés d'accord
le confinement il ya l'enjeu 2-2
au niveau de la prévention l'accès
facile aux arrêts que nous intervenants
on n'arrive pas à comprendre
et le politique nous dit voilà
cccc jette les balles entre le fédéral
le provincial
mais mais
et c'est toujours trop tard pour tenter
de trouver un sens au drame cette
adolescente est lancé une pétition
destinée à interpeller les élus et elle
a pour but justement de
l a pour but d' enfant d'augmenter la
surveillance de la part des
patrouilleurs dans les zones scolaires
des milieux à risque justement pour
protéger les jeunes enfants qu'est ce
qui me met en colère c'est que on dirait
que le gouvernement fait rien pour
justement ce que cette violence là il se
mérite et françois radio canada montréal